yeah the
the topic that i'm going to speak to
today
is connecting providers to their patient
data and as i'm
watching people i've got the chat pulled
up and i'm watching people saying um
someone just said that they were from
france i saw nigeria canada
uh my old uh hometown of atlanta georgia
i'm up here in upstate new york but yes
i am a ramblin wreck from georgia tech
uh thank you for joining us today given
the fact that
you know obviously healthcare is a
highly
we all have
healthcare is the same everywhere in
that we're always treating people we are
trying to make people healthy yet
the business of healthcare is highly
localized
and i was very much when i was putting
the slides together i will confess i was
sort of thinking of the concept of u.s
national level thing so i'm going to try
to be very conscientious as i'm going
through some of these topics and i start
throwing out terminology because
epidemiology healthcare et cetera is
just rife with terminology so i'm going
to try to not drown everyone in
lingo also when i just have to because
you know it's healthcare and we need
more acronyms i will try to make sure
that i am backing up and you know kind
of trying to at least give where that
acronym comes from
i want to also start with connecting
providers to their patient data so what
am i talking about there
and who rather
specifically i'm talking about in
today's discussion ambulatory providers
a lot of times when we start talking
about healthcare a lot of the uh papers
you'll read etc they're about hospitals
providers a doctor in a hospital doing a
surgery providing us a care providing an
intervention
well the world that i live in is
actually the other side of the coin it's
when the patients go home
i work with providers all over upstate
new york that are providing care in the
ambulatory setting it's a it's a mix of
both primary care and specialist care
but the point of it is that all the
providers that i work with are
ambulatory providers which means you can
ambulate in you talk to the doctor and
you ambulate out this is not inpatient
this is not uh uh emergency department
care this is going in for your annual
physical
uh trying to maintain and deal with
chronic diseases like chronic heart
failure what have you this is not that
the
the stuff that we always see on the news
in the evening you know you'll watch
your local news is like oh the emergency
department is reporting this or that
that's a little bit different than what
we're talking about here today
all right
so with that what is acuity's help
we are we the terminology we like to use
is that we are a population health
services company
we help
providers
make that transition to in america we
are making the transition from
transition from a world of fee for
service so you patient walks in patient
is given some care it is charged health
insurance pays for it
the american health care system is
moving away from this fee for service
model into this value-based payment
model which is more about trying to
codify and
document the conditions that people are
dealing with and provide a mechanism to
empower providers
to
really
treat people holistically and to try to
make sure that we're actually dealing
with all of the needs that patients have
this is a sea change in how health care
is provided because most medical office
models are based around the idea of have
patients come in we will do something
for them we give them an x-ray we do
whatever the patient walks out we get
paid value-based payment is a completely
different world and so what acuteness
does and i've got a picture up on the
screen of prior to kovan 19 the office
that we occupied hello river street in
troy new york and that is uh the rice
building in troy new york it's a lovely
uh
building that goes back to the 19th
century which i have not been inside of
for more than a few minutes at a time
in longer than i care to admit across
the bottom there so who are we
more broadly we are this independent
population health services company we
work with and are owned by cdphp which
is a regional health care provider here
in upstate new york and one of our
service vendors that we work with very
closely that i need to make sure i
acknowledge their role in what we do is
health catalyst so those are the three
logos that you see across the bottom
because what we are doing
the the position that acuities sort of
occupies
is trying to get everyone to work
together and i'll talk about that more
in just a moment but before i do
okay so who am i i like to joke that i
am the pirate captain i lead the data
science team here at acuity's health i
personally have a background in program
evaluation and program improvement i've
worked in areas such as ambulatory care
child welfare elder care and other human
services domains
rumor has it although this is just a
rumor and remains to be seen but rumor
has it i am a fan of the 18th letter of
the english alphabet
and yes i did actually choose this
picture very very very consciously so
on slack and in
zoom i use a picture of the pirate
captain if uh you are fans of british
humor you know this show if you don't
know the show you need to know the show
go watch it it's hysterical uh charles
darwin has never been so much fun but
the pirate captain only succeeds he only
survives literally to the end of the
show because of his crew
so the reason i chose this picture is
because sure i'm the one you're talking
today but this isn't really my work
the thing that i want to make sure that
i'm really transparent about is that
this is the work of a large group of
professionals that i have the pleasure
of working with and they have come
together to help us all create these
really interesting ways of trying to
connect
providers to their data across ehr
claims hie systems all of these
different data sources that tend to live
in their own silos and their own bubbles
it is this team
not me that created this and it is this
team
that is going to be able to make this
carry forward into the future
all right so technologies like i said i
did want to make sure
i throw their uh logo in here a couple
times we do work with a company called
health catalyst that helps provide some
of our back-end services
in terms of technologies used we use a
lot of r we use a lot of python we use a
little bit of javascript and
don't tell anybody
we still have some glick
but all jokes aside we also do we are uh
customers with our studio and we use
rstudio connect and we also use uh if
anybody really wants to know all the
dirty laundry in the back end we use uh
microsoft ms sql server for our backend
database driver so those are sort of the
suite of technologies that we use oh i
didn't put the logo up here but we also
have a what we call the report server
which uh runs uh docker instances so
those are sort of our suite of
technologies
when we started the cutis we were very
purposeful about trying to not have a
single technology or not have a single
language that we would try to implement
everything in we wanted to recognize
that data science is a rapidly growing
and changing field and that the reality
is that we should be trying to use the
best
tool for the job
and while people are
certainly welcome to argue about whether
or not we have done that in all
instances these were the best choices
for us at the time and we have been
trying to make sure that we are
empowering the people on our team
remember i said it's really about that
team so we were trying to make sure that
we were empowering the people on that
team to use the technologies that fast
that situation and their needs at that
moment so that's why we have tried to
make sure that we don't do i've worked
in at other places where everything has
to be done in spss or everything has to
be done in sas or everything has to be
done in r and we have taken the opposite
approach where we say let's just try to
figure out what the best tool for the
job is and then use that tool
so
uh you know there's some limits on that
i don't think we have anything
implemented in erlang yet but give us
time give us time
all right so some fun facts about
acuitis acuitous hence the logo we live
in this sometimes uncomfortable space
between insurance companies aka payers
and your doctor the provider
i tend to use the terminology of payer
and provider but when i say payer i mean
medical insurance companies and when i
say provider i mean your doctor or the
the practice sort of more generally
it is our job to help both succeed
we are currently importing just for some
context in terms of what we are dealing
with we import ehr data from 14
different vendors and we do so by a
variety of means including odbc
if you are familiar uh
how
ehrs are implemented here in the us the
consolidated clinical document or ccva
and just good old-fashioned csv
we are actually supporting over 200
practices in the capital district in
upstate new york region and we work with
11 different payer groups
and we do all that as a company that is
going to turn five next june so we are a
very young company we move very fast
we break things from time to time but we
what we are doing is trying to provide a
highly
fluid group of services to a very
diverse group of providers to help them
like i said
succeed and thrive in this value-based
payment uh regime and so we live in the
middle which is
sometimes uncomfortable because it's
difficult living in the middle of
between two different uh groups that
actually have a lot of the same common
interest they don't always see
themselves as having all of the same
common interests so we live in the
middle helping everyone understand how
actually
providers and payers really do have a
lot more overlap than they have in terms
of differences of interest
some context around the provider tools
that we're going to talk about let's
think about so i started this saying
that we're going to connect
providers to their data and that is what
we do
so let's think about what those those
data sources really are you have ehrs
which are these marvelly complex
relational data sources that have all of
the patient history the amount of data
that is
and by the way these screenshots no i
pulled these down from the vendor's
websites
so if there's phi in this not my fault
these are not screenshots from our
clients
but
uh an ehr is this incredibly complex
thing that is it's basically a filing
cabinet for everybody's healthcare data
and then you have the practice
management system which deals with
things like billing and upcoming
appointments helping you know you call
them up and say hi i'd like to see my
doctor and they say okay so we have an
appointment available at next tuesday at
two o'clock can you do that
that's what that practice management
system is in most practices these two
systems live independently of one
another they're connected there's
obviously the practice management system
can tell the ehr there's an appointment
so there has to be connectivity
yet at the same time they are actually
separate systems and then other groups
of data that exist
here in the united states we have what
we call health information exchanges to
help them information exchange i work
with most often is called hicks me and a
health information exchange sends out
what we call hl7 i know so much lingo i
hate healthcare's healthcare sometimes
so an hl7 message is just a fancy way of
saying xml and it is an xml message that
has some information about an event or a
patient that gets sent out over yield
interwebs
and so that information goes out and
usually gets dumped into the ehr and
notifies the provider of some advantage
or some something
again all that's going into the ehr and
then of course the other source of data
that providers are having to deal with
increasingly are clients
so a patient you know the practice
management system the ehr know what's
going on here
but there's this bigger picture of when
you start trying to talk about a
holistic picture of what someone is
medically there's this larger picture of
of what are other providers doing when
there are you know daa signed and all
this legal stuff gets taken care of how
can we leverage the incredible power of
claims data the incredible power of
these health information exchange
systems and all the data providers have
historically collected in their ehr and
practice management system and the
reality
is that that big holistic picture is
what i'm referring today to as
population health
and there isn't really a stock tool you
can't go buy a system for this
and in fact i'm not even sure at this
point you can because the needs are so
regional they're so dependent upon what
that practice is doing at that time here
in the united states the health
department of health and human services
comes out with a new medical model
roughly every three minutes or so that
providers may or may not decide to get
involved with so the the complexity of
health care
just within the united states let alone
the rest of the world but just within
the united states
so that's why companies like the cuis
have been starting uh starting up is to
help support providers in all of us
so
now of course the obvious question is
okay so you say that you're you're
supporting people with this so what does
that mean so i'm going to take you
through what i'm going to refer to as
some population help tools these are
some tools that we have provided for our
clients
now i've already said that you know this
is obviously very tricky because there's
all these different data sources they
don't necessarily want to talk to one
another so
effectively what i've introduced you to
is the gordy and not modern medicine so
we're going to be a little bit alexander
the great here and we're going to cut
that boardian knot
and there's only one way that i know of
to do this
and that's by getting everybody at the
table and involved
so when i show you these tools these are
not things that were like made in in the
back office somewhere
and some people the data science team
got together like oh this is a cool idea
that's not how we do things we are not
providing a product like microsoft where
we work on it for a couple of years and
then shove it out we put it in the store
and we ask you just
people to buy it
we have contracts with providers they
need services from us what happens in
terms of how we actually get to these
tools
is the providers or the payers come to
us and say hey there's this need we need
to be able to communicate around this we
need to be able to help people navigate
this
specific space maybe we need to help
with transitions of care so when people
leave inpatient setting how do we make
sure that that works how do we make sure
that the primary care provider is
following up with that patient
and just if you think about that
that transition of care you have a
patient leaving the hospital
and they're going to go home and
it would be ideal for their primary care
provider to follow up and provide
contact and you know check in with them
do we need to talk about your
medications how are you feeling do you
need to come in and see me back let me
go ahead and schedule that for you
that's what we're talking about around
transition of care and it's really hard
because what's happened traditionally is
ehrs
get this message and it gets dumped into
the ehr and it may or may not generate
an alert for the provider
and there's more people at an actual
practice than just the doctors doing
work they have a support team around
them
so i want to introduce you to the first
tool that's going to help us cut this
gourdian knot
is the hospital activity monitor or ham
now you will note that the picture that
i have on the screen at this point
is of a lump of ham and not the tool
which gets us into this really funny
thing about healthcare is i can't show
you a lot of what we do directly
because it's literally chock full of phi
and i don't really want to violate those
federal laws so i have to be a little
bit careful here i'm going to i do have
some other screenshots but i just want
to acknowledge the pink elephant in the
room of we're doing things that we can't
directly show
so what is the hospital activity monitor
ham as we call it and you'll see that a
lot of our
there's a joke with everything we we
have to have our fun
the ham report is a daily email that
goes out it is actually provided to the
sites as a as an excel file and in that
excel file is going to be a whole bunch
of tabs and those tabs have things like
here's the list uh doctor you know
whoever here are the list of your
patients who within the last 24 hours
were admitted to the hospital
so here they are and what the advent
reason is these are all uh patients that
have consented to having their
information exchanged over the hie the
health information exchange they have
consented to that that this doesn't just
happen by magic they have to consent
if they do consent and they allow their
information to be sent out over hicks me
to the provider we pick it up and we
give the doctors a report say hey
these are your patients that have been
admitted inpatient in the last
24 hours we also have a list of here are
the patients who are discharged from the
hospital in the last 24 hours so they've
gone home
somebody should probably follow up with
them and again there's context so you
can see in terms of you know what type
of stuff we're providing some of it's
really boring the mrn the name of the
date of birth just helps people know
what we're talking about but if you go
in and you look at some of the event
information where where are they going
where did they were they admitted to or
discharged from
so
you know hospitals that we have up here
in the capital district places like
albany med or st peters
this is you know what i mean by an admit
uh facility or discharge location
why were they inpatient in the first
place what was that primary reason what
was the discharge date if there is one
that's obviously only on the discharges
and for context for the provider again
driven by the hie
how many recent er visits have they had
how many recent inpatient visits have
they have because someone who has an
inpatient stay and you can look for wow
in the last year they've had seven ed
visits and now they're impatient that's
a very different patient than someone
who just went in you know overnight now
we have to try to gauge what is the
severity of the of the patient's needs
so we try to provide a snapshot picture
of what's going on
the provider still has the ehr if they
have further questions they can go
diving through the incredibly rich data
set that is the ehr this is a snapshot
that allows the provider a nurse a care
manager to make rapid decisions about
which patients really need to be
prioritized for follow-up on that
transition of care which patients need
to be followed up while they're actually
in the hospital what have you
and all of this thing is about really
providing patient connectivity between
the ambulatory primary care provider and
the patient when they're going in and
out of the hospital so that is
well a whole lot of ham
another tool that we have which we call
the chronic conditions report or ccr
and this is another excel file that is
generated and sent out and uh both of
these uh so the actually back up the
hospital activity monitor is actually a
python script and ccr is an r script and
these run on what we refer to as our
report server which is our
docker-powered system for emailing out
large numbers of excel files that we
developed internally
the uh this is again an excel file like
i said and this is something that we
send out every other week to a site
and so if you are familiar with an ehr
one of the things that you would know is
that ehrs are
i
kind of compare oh you can't see this
because it's a property but i have a
filing cabinet in front of me they are a
patient filing capital
all of the information gets put into the
right little you know folder inside the
ehr for that patient and
it's a marvelously rich data source
but
ehrs are not good at providing a 35 000
foot view of what's going on so if you
take off in a plane and you're flying
over you know wherever and you look down
you have a completely different view
of the country side than you do if you
are driving down the road and i would
say the ehr is like driving down the
road and using you know google to uh get
you from point a to point b
and this chronic conditions report this
is what you see when you get in the
plane because this is full panel data
ehrs have obviously full panel data and
when i say full panel data what i mean
is all the patients at the site
so ehrs have that but when you use an
ehr you are looking at just my data or
just your data you're not looking at
that 30 000 foot view the ccr is that 30
000 foot view so we break it down and we
say okay so
how many patients have diabetes at your
practice and of those who do what was
their last a1c value
because providers need a way of saying
hey you know i'd like to be able to do
this new intervention i've got this this
new technology or i've got this new care
manager who's joining my practice and we
want to really be able to target people
who have an a1c overnight
well this ccr what we like to say is
this democratizes that data because
without having to come to us or to come
to anyone else the provider now has the
ability to say all right
who are all my patients who have
diabetes with an a1c overnight
they have the ability using this excel
file to literally make that list and
then they can hand that off to their
care manager in the office say please
let's go provide some services for these
patients
it it makes it rapid it makes it so they
have full transparency into what's going
on
and you can see the entire list of
things you know that we are providing in
terms of the types of chronic conditions
and labs that we target on this and
we're adding you know more slowly it
also provides
a
high level view
of what are those conditions you can see
a risk assessment at this particular uh
provider uh at this particular ten they
do a what we call provider risk
assessment the provider puts patients
into risk levels of one two three and
four based on clinical criteria
patients who are in level four are
referred for care management uh and that
cm active is are they active in care
management hicks need consenting so we
you know can we share their data over
hicks need do they have diabetes this is
how many and an ehr isn't really good at
this because that's not really what it
was designed to do and see i can finally
show a screenshot because that smphi
but
this is the kind of data that an ehr is
not well equipped to provide to a
provider
the next one here and i've just got one
or two more slides here before i wrap up
but this is what we call our pre-visit
planning document so jane doe is not a
real patient she's not a real person so
this is a dummy document but it is
emblematic of what our pre-visit
planning tool is again like i was saying
an ehr is super complicated and the ehr
provides all the detail
all
of their a1c's about values all of their
history
so we developed this pre-visit planning
tool to help providers
get ready to see you so hopefully in the
day or two the week what have you before
your appointment when you go in to see
your provider they sit down and they do
a chart review they go through and they
think about who you are medically they
prepare themselves and because of our
role trying to help providers succeed in
value-based payment contracts
some of the space here is occupied by
information that will help that provider
know what things they should be doing so
for example down here
we have some uh lists of cervical cancer
screenings and this you know in that
case there's something for them to do
um but we have a list of things that
these are coming these measures are ecq1
measures for those of you in the united
states these are measures that the
doctor should be considering about how
am i going to fill on this patient this
particular patient is apparently very
complicated but this is a little over
the top in terms of an example but it
gives you an idea of what type of
information is on it how we're trying to
help providers identify opportunities to
close gaps in care
it goes down and has you know an er and
inpatient say so again we're integrating
data from the ehr from hicks knee from
claims all this is getting dumped into
this one single document that your
primary care provider can review
and try to mentally get ready to provide
you with the best possible care at that
point of contact in the office they can
sit down and they can see your the
orders you know they can say oh did you
follow up on that what have you
then if the provider has further
questions again they still have that ehr
they can still go to that and they can
open that up and go looking through and
go okay so i see that your last a1c was
really high it was a 12 that's
it's not good but they can go into the
ehr and say okay you had 112.
everything else was pretty good and you
had 112 that's different than a patient
that's got lots of 12s
and 12 is a not good a1c so
they still may have to go to the ehr to
really kind of put that full picture
together but we're providing a snapshot
of information that really helps the
provider get their head in the right
space so that when they walk in to see
you they are ready they know what's
going on and they have some context for
where you are medical
the last tool i've got i wanted to talk
about just because this is an r and
epidemiology thing
kind of seems like we need a shiny
application shown off somewhere in this
thing
so this is a shiny app that we made and
it also i wanted to use this as an
opportunity to highlight something
that's not ehr driven a lot of our tools
are because we are connecting providers
to their data ehr driven of course they
are
this appointment trends application is
not in fact there is
almost no ehr date in this thing
whatsoever also fun because that means i
can do screenshots
but
what this is really being driven by is
by that practice management tool you've
got appointments coming up you've got
appointments showing up or not
if you would all recall
back in march of 2020 the state of new
york shut itself down
and so what this tool came about was
over about a weekend after cobit 19 hit
and new york city and the new york state
uh just a day or two later started
shutting down
providers started calling us and saying
i know that people are not going to show
up for their appointments
i know people patients aren't going to
show up for their appointments i know
that my numbers are decreasing of
appointments but i don't have a little
ability to wrap my head around what that
means i don't know how bad
we were able to very rapidly put
together a
a tool it started off as a flex
dashboard that we emailed the people and
later we were able to
put it together as a shiny application
that now lives actually uh on in our
network
and that purple line is 20 20. and you
can see
the fall off the crater there is right
there as we go into march of 2020 when
covet 19 causes new york state to shut
down hard to deal with the epidemic
and the green line up there is what it
should look like from 2019. so a little
bit of a difference
this tool is also was able to be
adapted
to help providers understand okay i know
my in-person numbers are crashing that's
what that screenshot was but they were
also implementing remote care all of a
sudden
kind of wild you could go to your doctor
on zoom
and like have an entire medical visit
where you didn't even have to like be in
the same room with your provider and we
all of a sudden we shoved medicine in
the 21st century and the practice sites
were working really hard to implement
these technologies and they were
honestly doing a really good job what
they didn't know was where they were
they plugging the hole they said i know
my inpatient number my in-person numbers
are down
am i plugging that hole with these
remote visits and so this tool actually
has the ability to let us go in and
track and of course it varies by the
site and it varies by the type of care
provided but we were able to start
helping providers understand
yes your in-person visits are way way
down this is to the extent that you're
able to make that up using remote
technologies remote visits etc doing
phone calls what have you to really try
to make up that hole make up that gap
plug that hole
this was a tool that came about
i want to say the initial version of
this uh we put together literally in one
weekend
and we were able to get this out and by
the end of the year it is now a standing
thing that standing application that the
practice some of our practice sites
continue to use here in 2021 to
understand what what their numbers are
looking like trending over time because
simply put
appointments mean revenue so while you
know one blip you know depends how much
revenue depends on what the appointment
is your appointments are going up
revenue will
eventually follow
so
just one more application that we were
able to do to help them see that thirty
thousand foot view of what their
practices look like
all right
so
that was my uh presentation thank you so
much for everything i put a link up
there i made the uh slides that i just
went through publicly available there on
my gitlab page and
there you go for everyone who needed it
your obligatory parkour chunk
thank you so much andy i really
appreciate your energy as well
um i am the pirate
you definitely are
with the
while i go over to the slido for some of
the questions do you mind copying and
pasting the slides into the chat or just
that link there
and just a reminder if anybody joined a
little bit later we do have a slider
link where you can ask questions too
or upvote other questions
but andy one of the most upvoted
questions so far is are there are
packages that help with ehr data
wrangling
good question
so
that is something that i skimmed over
when i went through the uh discussion
around technologies
there it is i i skimmed over that so
what we actually do i i did uh say that
the
technology provider that we use to help
us do what we do as health catalysts
what we actually wind up doing is health
catalyst provides a lot of our back-end
services in terms of etl
and they have a set of tools that they
have developed which we use to actually
help us manage all of that complexity
and so what we actually do we describe
our data warehouse as a as a later take
and our that first level of well we
technically do elt but we extract loads
and then later we do the transformations
we use the health catalyst tools to
actually do that initial uh
export out of the ehrs into the data
warehouse so no we are not using any art
packages for that there
are really good art packages to help you
with diagnosis groupings and things like
that that are useful
but
if they're they're very well made b
tools where you're not using those at
this point
thank you
nicole do you want to go back and forth
with me for the slider questions
yeah absolutely um
the next one andy is about large data
how do you deal with large data sets
greater than 100 gigabytes using r i
tend to use sas to do data wrangling
since r is limited by ram size is there
a way to solve this in r
so i guess the first question
that i would
address with that is so if you have very
very large data 100 gigabytes is pretty
is pretty big
what are you trying to do with that so
the solution that i would suggest if you
are doing some kind of a machine
learning model would be different than
if you are trying to do some sort of
summarization
because
if what you are trying to do is say uh
so practice management data is something
that tends to scale up into the omg
scale because just think about how many
appointments a provider has
in a day
you know i'm talking to a provider like
one doctor and there's often more than
one doctor in a site and we're working
with over 200 sites so our practice
management data is
large it's deep
i
don't usually need to do a machine
learning model off of you know the full
cohort of that data so what we actually
do and what i would recommend if this is
a relevant uh opportunity for you is to
use a database server
because yes r is memory bound and but if
what i really need for example going
back to this
our appointment trends going up or down
that calculation of how many
appointments are happening in a day
that is not actually being calculated in
r i'm actually offloading that through
dbplier onto the database server and
it's calculating the number of
appointments per day
r is only in this in the instance of
this particular uh application it's
having to graph a number of you know
about 50k it's a it's an integer and
this is the monthly view so there's only
you know there's two lines there's only
12 months in the year so at most 24 or
48 you know data points so
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
appointments
but i can slim it down to
48 data points and r is you really you
can you can graph that on the pocket
calculator
so if you can use a database server i
would recommend that if you can't
uh there are virtu using virtual
machines other jobs that i've done where
i needed to do machine learning models
on very very large data sets i used
virtual machines where i could actually
have an arbitrary amount of ram but
there you have to have the budget to pay
for it
thanks andy and i um i meant to say this
before but if we're getting to anyone's
question and you want to jump in and add
any more context or follow up feel free
to unmute yourselves
it should let you do so and if anyone
has issues with that let me know um but
abdullah i know you had put your name
there and that was your question so i
just wanted to see if
you had any follow-up too
can i have something sure
thank you
hey andy just wondering about this ehr
data is that accessible to anybody or
you have to go through health catalyst
or something like that
so so the ehr data
uh
to help me answer your question uh
where are you on the globe so i can tell
you what let me just answer this like
i'm in chicago okay you're in chicago
okay so so you're in the same healthcare
regime as i am in terms of federal uh
laws and such
so in order to get access to the ehr
data we actually wind up doing the very
first step that we have to go through
and
now i'm like gosh
i wish some of the folks on my on on the
team that are
doing this day-to-day were here to help
me with this but the very first step is
what we have what you would have to do
is get a daa you actually have to get
permission to access that data so
obviously in america we have
what we call phi laws which very tightly
control
who can have access to private health
data and those laws are very important
and if you violate them there are very
significant consequences may i suggest
you do not violate those so the very
first step is to get a daa with the
practice
and then once we have that daa with the
practice and the the doctor has to say
acute is health i i am licensing
acuitous health to be a third-party
vendor and they are going to work with
me to manage my ehr data then we reach
out to their vendor
all scripps cerner whoever and we start
working with them and the details here
kind of depend on on
who the vendor is and how that
particular site has that tool set up and
we start working with them on an
information exchange so that we can
access that data so that's where we
start getting into you know it might be
an odc connection it might be a flat
file what have you
and then we are able to pull that down
our data is
it is in the cloud but it's in a phi
grade you know the expensive grade of
all vms because no we can't just let
people access that data because
obviously it's it's private we have
information that
people have the right to have privately
and and keep private so
that is data that hence why i had to be
sort of careful and make you know
silly ccr jokes and uh you know ham
jokes throughout this presentation
because
you know the actual spreadsheet of the
hospital activity monitor i
didn't want if i had put it up here it
would have been two-thirds you know
obvious skated out i would have had to
have like made it really hard to breed
so it wouldn't have been much fun to
look at so i felt like it was better to
approach this but no we have to be very
careful around healthcare and data
exchange within this world
which is good but it also makes
everything complicated did i answer your
question
yes you did thank you so much andy
it's like i hope i wasn't rambling i was
on youtube
thanks andy um jocelyn i see you had
just asked a question in the zoom chat
and i wanted to pass the mic over to you
if that's okay to ask that live
yes thanks rachel so my question is how
do you track patients medical history
when you
look at their
service chart
because during the years a patient could
change their plans and have multiple
patient id or insurance plans id so how
do you track their medical history
that is a really good question actually
so
inside our platform we actually use an
mdm tool called multi-view and what
multi-view does and no tool of this
nature is perfect
we have tuned ours to a place that we're
very comfortable with but is it perfect
nope will it ever be
nope
but what this does is it allows us to
connect so i mentioned that we work with
i believe yeah we work with 11 different
payer groups a multiple different uh
provider groups
and no so you mentioned the complexity
of
i went from
uh
blue shield to cd php insurance
for example at some point in the past i
used to have uh blue shield right now i
have cd php insurance so i have a new uh
provider i have a new payer id on that i
have some number within uh with blue
shield
that i was a record number with them and
i have a new record number one cd php
which is obviously not the same and yes
we
up to a point are able to track people
across those because we use this
multiview that will go in and look at
first name last name date of birth
gender and a whole bunch of other
criteria to try to guess
that andy in this data set is the same
andy as in this data set
we also have to be very careful about
that because there are
very complex rules around when we can
combine that data and share it and when
we can't again because we have to be
very conscientious around privacy so
anytime we start doing things that any
any process that starts to walk across
multiple data sets we have to stop take
a deep breath and really really really
think it through from a legal and
privacy standpoint to make sure that
we're not doing something inappropriate
but yeah we use a tool called multiview
to help us say
the other part that can be fun that can
be uh
complicated
is you you as an individual patient over
the course of your life will have
multiple you know providers you know
just imagine as a simple example a kid
who goes from having a pediatrician to
eventually a family medicine
practitioner and
that could be in multiple ehrs so we're
also able to on behalf of the payer
groups that we work with
map that you know progression across
different ehr systems so we can say hey
you know this is how that particular
healthcare for this patient who has had
your insurance for all those years has
been developing
but again that's something that both has
both technical and
legal and privacy aspects to it
thank you very much
awesome i'll take us back to the slack
for the next or i'm sorry the slido for
the next one
um i'm gonna ask one that i'm
particularly interested in the answer of
andy and it's are there other quick
tools you've had to make in shiny like
the appointment trends app oh gosh yes
uh we
we
we we uh generate shiny apps uh
weekly
uh so things that we are doing in
shining right now
uh on a technical side so i mentioned
that we use that health catalyst
platform and they have a number of tools
that go through and do that etl and all
those jobs we actually have been
starting to develop our own shiny
applications to help us manage the data
warehouse so that we can better have
better insight into what's running how
long do those things run we have a
series of shiny dashboards that we built
that go beyond what the health catalyst
platform provides out of the box to help
us meet our needs
i related that not actually shiny but
it's kind of fun internally we also use
slack um
probably too much and so if you happen
to work someplace that you slack you
know understand the emoji hell that
we've all been living in in the last 18
months but
um the other thing that we do is that we
have our markdown reports and for
example some of those are about our etl
jobs so we actually have channels for
our dev and prod environments at a uh
one of the members of of our team who's
absolutely phenomenal she wrote in our
markdown script that runs every morning
and it puts out a list of these are your
jobs that failed last night you need a
human to go look at them and that is
something that gets them dumped into
nobody actually looks at it on the our
markdown generator is is actually
ignored what we use is the side effect
of it that gets shoved into slack and
we're able to read that it's in our
communications platform and it's from an
r script that's running on our studio
connect but it gets dumped into slack
which is where we live moment the moment
and it says hey these etl jobs failed
and the human needs to go figure out why
and fix it and every morning the the
what we call the io team
looks at that and starts figuring out
how to make our etl uh spin better
uh and then in terms of the providers we
have a number and i couldn't go through
them all in part um i was told to keep
it about half an hour and
we have you know so many shiny apps we
have things that are helping people with
uh financial analytics we have things
that are helping folks uh with uh care
management we have a whole bunch of
different things that we have been doing
that kind of try to walk that gamut of
data sources that we deal with
so yeah shiny is a
a very important part of what we do as
our static armor account files
that's amazing thanks andy
toyan i know you had a a few great
questions that you had copied over to
the slido um and just wanted to pass the
mic over to you to have you ask those if
that's okay
certainly thanks rachel yeah one
question that came to my mind when you
were speaking about i think it was the
ccr
and identifying special populations is
whether or not you ever incorporate data
from like remote patient um
monitoring devices is that something
that any of the sites that you
support use
not yet but it is something that i have
been having multiple conversations with
uh once a couple of the provider sites
that we work with that are underneath a
single tin
their uh cio and i have been having
conversations about that
and
somewhere here behind me i actually got
i don't remember the brand that they're
gonna that they're talking about
implementing but i actually bought some
of the devices so i could start playing
with the api
because yeah we are trying to figure out
how to do that
and start actually doing that and that
is i
that that is something that is in the
next
oh
two to five years i think is going to be
extremely exciting in this ambulatory
space i mean everything i'm you know
this is a garment a lot of people have
apple watches just this like
the other day i was having a really
really awful day and
the watch kept telling me that my blood
pressure was up which the end result of
that was i threw the watch across the
room and told it to shut up but
i didn't need an r api to tell me that i
was stressed but but being able to track
that like being able to track heart rate
and blood pressure data
and be able to start integrating that
into ehrs and be able to connect all
those pieces
the um the other thing that is
personally very interesting to me is cgm
data so continuous glucose monitoring
data for diabetes my wife is a type 1
diabetic and so she is
a user a patient using a continuous
glucose monitor
and
to be able to integrate that more
holistically with her uh providers ehr
is something that i think is really
really interesting and if i manage to
help be part of providing that that'll
be very very cool uh but i would love to
be able to provide that because you know
the doctor's gonna run an a1c and say oh
so mrs cohen it looks like blah blah
blah but but to be able to then and
right now he has to go to a completely
separate system he has to log into a
a separate system and he can't put those
two pieces together so yeah i think to
be able to connect those is where
ambulatory care has to get too quickly
to really
take it to the next level with patient
care
sadly i'm not doing that yet
thanks andy
um another anonymous question was are
you monitoring for outbreaks like
respiratory viruses or
microbes that could spread easily in a
hospital setting and what would be your
latency on that
so we are not doing that because like i
was saying earlier our what we are
really focused on is ambulatory care so
that would really be more of an uh an
emergency department they would have
that kind of data
eventually through the hie we would get
that but no that would be something we
would tend to just rely on the local
emergency departments to use to actually
track because
our providers aren't really doing that
kind of testing either
the only way that we would even get that
kind of outbreak data would be via the
hie
because
ambulatory providers
aren't doing just routine testing that
kind of stuff yet
we
are doing some stuff to help
the providers manage uh patients with
covent so patients who have had covid
and have tested positive especially in
that transition of care
uh circumstance where they're coming and
they're being discharged from an
inpatient state due to covid we are
highlighting that for providers
based on hie messaging so that they know
and can you know provide appropriate
transition of care and follow-up care
for those patients but the that type of
community outbreak monitoring is pretty
it's out of scope for what we really do
thank you
uh nicole i'll turn it over to you for
some of the other questions especially
because you have the fd background and
we'll say things much better than me i
don't know about that rachel but sure um
andy there's a little bit of a
conversation that's been spanning the
chat about practice data sets and how to
get your hands on a data set where you
can
play around with r and do some epi
related work but not have to access phi
do you know any
data sets or any sources that people
could use
so
it's
weird timing on that one so in my in
another part of my life i'm an adjective
professor at the albany college of
pharmacy and health sciences and i have
been wanting to answer that for my
students because what i've been wanting
to do in the spring
semester is actually provide them with
an ehr that's all fake data
so
nicole i think you guys had said that
you were uh going to put out a slack
channel
yes
i
am blanking on the name of the ehr
but i will actually put out
a uh uh something on i'll put something
into that slack channel because i found
an open source ehr that you can spin up
and one of the cool things that they
actually have is they have a sql script
that would in a me sequel database would
actually allow you to generate uh its
anonymized data so that you can actually
have your own your own private ehr to
kind of play with and experiment with
and it would be running in a database
server that you would control
so that yeah that's actually something
that i'm i'm actively pursuing so once i
can tell that story i'll try to work on
that here in the next couple nights and
i'll try to put like out some
instructions for how to do that because
yes that is definitely possible
awesome thanks andy
um
yeah just muted someone but
yeah i was trying to ask a question and
the audio was going in and out
was there a question that someone wanted
to
to ask i can go back to the slido if not
they'll give a second in case that
person wants to come back and try again
robert i think there might be a issue
with your audio but if you want to put
it into the chat we can ask it too
or we can go to
one other from the the slido first too
yeah i'll ask a slido question and we'll
see if that question comes through um
what kind of features might your team
engineer about a single diagnosis for
example if someone had an icd-10 code
associated with diabetes in the last
three years
so if someone
what would we hit me with the what would
we do part again
what i got stuck down in the details
the question went away but it was sorry
i was i was marking it as answered as we
went through but it was what kind of
features might your team engineer about
a single diagnosis
for example
if someone had an icd-10 code associated
with diabetes in the last three years
okay
so
that's
what feature if we're uh by using the
word feature i am assuming that we're
talking about machine learning models at
this point which is
awesome
um
the answer to that is going to be really
dependent upon what the ques obviously
what what is the question that we're
trying to answer
uh some things that we have done for
example and diabetes is a feature in
this model is things like uh what are
the odds or what a machine learning
model trying to predict the risk of
readmission to an inpatient stay after
discharge so we have a readmission risk
model and you know chronic diseases play
a part in that model because people with
lots of you know chronic diseases are
more likely to be very obviously sick
and therefore more likely to be admitted
so that would be um an example of
something where we would use something
like a diabetes diagnosis and even more
importantly things connected to their
a1c because that would help us
understand if it was a diabetes related
inpatient state or not
so things like that would be used in a
model to help predict something like a
readmission risk other things that we
have been starting to work on
are trying to for example understand
disease progression so you for example
have that the ques the person asking the
question started with a diagnosis of
diabetes
if you have diabetes and the question is
going to become what what uh types of
neuropathies are you likely to develop
so what types of complications are you
likely to develop and when how long is
that progression going to look like the
other side that we're a little bit more
active on is actually diabetes becoming
the uh
the output the consequence is trying to
go so here are patients with
pre-diabetes of all those that we know
who have pre-diabetes
who are the most at risk of becoming
diabetics in the next three to five
years so it's i know i'm flipping the
question on its head but that is this
idea of disease progression being going
up to diabetes and actually being
formally diagnosed with diabetes instead
of just pre-diabetes and then if you
have diabetes you know initially you
would have um
if you developed diabetes in that regard
you're a type ii and so you'd have tight
uncomplicated type 2 diabetes and
eventually as the disease progresses
that those patients are going to start
developing you know it can impact your
kidneys and lead to chronic kidney
disease things like that so there's
opportunities in modeling around who is
most at risk for things for consequences
of that what diabetes and any chronic
disease
be it uh you know
asthma what have you can have no side
effects that are holistic and systemic
thanks andy as we get to the top of the
hour here i know some people might have
to jump so i just want to have nicole
give another plug for the slack channel
as well because we can answer some of
the unanswered
ones there
yeah i'll go join that slack channel so
i'll
happy to continue the conversation
yeah so i'm going to drop the link in
the zoom chat here and i think we'll be
able to share it
after the fact as well somehow but any
questions that didn't get answered or
that you think about after the fact feel
free to throw those in the slack channel
and
andy has told us that he will tell us
more about the practice data set
question there too so
i'm dropping this link oops
not the zoom link i have to find the
slack link um i'm dropping the slack
link in the zoom chat now
and we can continue any discussions over
there
awesome and if anybody wants to
unmute themselves and ask a question
live now i also want to give everyone
the opportunity to to do so
i could take unmuting yourself as
raising your hand
hey david
hey rachel
andy uh really interesting um
presentation thank you what's um so
what's a little
unclear to me
is um how do you measure how successful
um
your activities or your your products or
shiny dashboards are
oh good question
and
that one is ultimately a
perv
i have a really simple you know there's
a there's a cop out answer i could say
well the people that ask this horse tell
us they like it that's a cop-out answer
though um a better answer is so with uh
as and this is actually connected to why
we have been trying to convert more of
our tools to shiny
so if i send out you know here i was
earlier apparently i drew all over my
screen i didn't even notice that
sorry about that um
but but so we have that idea of that ccr
report or the ham report those are email
reports
and you're actually right in that i or i
suspect her right and that i i don't
know if someone opens up the ccr i it's
it once it goes out as an email
assuming it doesn't get rejected and we
do track that so that we can follow up
with like hey why is this email address
not work anymore
we don't know if someone opens it so we
are reliant on so i i represent the data
science team at acuteness we do have
what we call a practice intelligence
team that has constant communication
with our sites
you know they have regular touch points
with them going on they talk about the
tools so we get some feedback that way
but one of the things and one of the big
driving reasons for why we've been
trying to go more and more in terms of
using shiny is because there we can
better actually say hey
this is how many user people actually
use this this is how many you know
people were able to go in with that in
other cases with things like following
up on transitions of care we've actually
been able to do some very simple you
know starting to look at analyses where
we start saying can we bend that curve
and start increasing the number of
primary care visits that happen after a
discharge
but but a lot of it is going to be what
i would call a process measure where
we're trying to look at you know people
utilizing the tools emotionally and
whatnot and shiny is way way way better
for that than any uh an emailed excel
file is
that's that's really interesting because
um as as
somebody as somebody who goes to a
doctor i i would have thought the answer
might have been
um
there's like an improvement
or at least not a degradation in
you know some key lab tests you know for
for
patients who have specific kinds of
conditions
and
depending upon what the intervention is
that might be it
i guess we're doing a number of
different things but
you know if
you are for example i know uh there are
a couple of providers who are targeting
diabetes so
there we would be able to use a1c
as
as a as a proxy for for any kind of an
impact but in other cases you know
because
and this is sort of the the funky part
about this
that ccr or the one of the terms that i
use is that the point of it is to use to
democratize the data
and one of the
honestly in a way unfortunate side
effects of that is i don't always know
or have transparency into how providers
are using it so i don't know necessarily
to look
so a doctor can get that chronic
conditions report you go up i got this
thing and i'm going to target diabetes
i don't hear about that then i don't
even know to follow that up
because in order to get that list of
patients they want to go do you know
work with they don't have to ask me
anymore i've i've almost i in a way
we've cut ourselves out of the loop
and so they can go do that thing and we
don't even know to look so
like monitoring lab values across all
lab values across all sites
looking for signals is guaranteed to be
or you know lead you down to the path of
false signals
so yeah in a way
they would have to come to us and and
say hey you know we'd like to work with
you on a program you know improvement
plan and evaluation to see if this is
effective and then
absolutely what you're saying is true
if someone comes to us and says i'd like
to do this can you help me track the
outcome then we would start looking at
appropriate lab values that might be
proxies for improved patient health but
they could also do something without
even telling us
okay
um andrea or andrea i see that you'd
unmuted us as well and i wanted to give
you a chance to ask your question
oh
i can't hear you yet
but if you have an issue with the audio
you feel free to use the chat too
nicole do you see
any other questions that we haven't
really touched upon yet
can i ask a follow-up to the diabetes
modeling question sure um so the there
were two sort of uh potential
applications you said like for example
readmission risk or
um the likelihood of complications given
the fact that they have uh diabetes or
some other icd-10 code fill in the blank
if you know that one of the most
important predictors for that is some
kind of metric that let's say comes from
a blood panel or white blood cell counts
or something along those lines is there
an implementation of this model and sort
of like an iterative loop where the
physician who sees this patient will
know or have an action item to get the
blood panel to
best predict whether readmission is
highly likely for a patient at a later
date you know is there a feedback loop
sort of to make sure patient outcomes
improve
yeah that could be that is something
that we could implement um
that would
most likely already be driven
unless we came up with some sort of a
novel
lab you know correlation that's probably
already going to be driven
natively by the ehr in which case we
would just
offload that to the ehr to drive you
know getting that lab completion and all
of that getting those results into the
ehr
um
but no i mean what you're saying
absolutely makes sense
one of the things though you use a word
that is worth highlighting which is
feedback loop and one of the things that
we are very conscientious about doing
anytime
if it's a tool or a model or anything
else
is involving the provider so
so not only would they you know a
provider ask us for some sort of a model
or something like we admission risk but
we would also have those people involved
in the development of the model because
what we have found is not only does that
increase the trust in the model it also
gets people to really start using it
because anytime you have a model it's a
model it's not reality it's not perfect
and
having them having those providers
involved from the very beginning in
terms of that feedback loop of talking
about what this model is helps them get
the understanding of well when is the
model right when is the model likely a
little bit off you know what are the
weaknesses of that model so having a
feedback loop on any data science
project back and forth between those
domain experts and the people doing you
know the data science and the technical
side is critical
thanks andy i know we're about 10
minutes over so i just want to be
respectful of your time especially if
you have to run to another meeting too
i do have a one that i need to get to
here at some point
okay
so
thank you so much i know there's a few
other unanswered questions is okay if we
just ask you
one last one which was how
i see this one i've been upvoted how do
you suggest our users normalize our use
when so many people are using sas or
spss
fun question i have been accused of
doing this uh
our advocacy is something i have been
accused of before
so what i would actually say is um
so previously i worked at the new york
state department of health and we had an
organization within that it was called
eb cot
which was epidemiology and biostatistics
community of practice
you know because there needed to be
another acronym in healthcare
and
within the the bounds of eb cop what i
was able to start doing was starting a
conversation around both r and
ultimately also about version control
but but trying to like start talking
about how it could be used
ultimately having a new a language
that's a little bit different than say
sas if you're in a sas shop
or an spss shop or what have you
having ultimately a champion who is in
some form of a leadership role you know
start identify i would say if if you are
in a leadership position then you have
the opportunity to start pushing that
conversation
otherwise it helps to have someone who
is in a leadership position who is open
to the idea of you know maybe we can do
some things that are different maybe we
can do some things that are
you know can broaden our horizons here
in terms of the technologies that we're
using and get that champion and we were
able to use this idea of eb cop as sort
of that proxy for that champion
and we started having getting people to
talk about it we started holding
workshops on doing art and how to get
people up to that those skill levels and
working with uh the department of health
i t to get our installed on people's
workstations so that they could actually
start using r which is how we were able
to make some headway there in a place
that is has a lot of sas users
um
but yeah i think having a process where
you have both a champion and a process
to start enabling people is are both
going to be the two critical steps for
that
that's awesome
thank you so much andy i know you have
to run to your next meeting but i really
really appreciate you sharing your
insights with us and answering
everyone's questions
i'm excited to see that slack channel
grow too and we can answer some of the
unanswered
ones there too yeah thank you for the
good question really good questions
thank you all for joining as well have a
great rest of the day
[Music]
you